okay well now I start the video okay
welcome to this video playing not coddle
an asado this is a Cuba and Cuban flag
we get there the Kings in young hmm I'd
get less crew in France recently I don't
know sir no particular reason probably
just coincidence yeah playing the Bishop
e3 line also known as the Eagle Ridge
system something that I want to look at
more closely yeah f5s the recent trend
down in former times they played yes is
going for that they played more more of
them aged 50 night h6 this is an
interesting way to play quite aggressive
and for black black wants to play
exactly age 6 g5 and put the night on f4
and this is even happening in cases
where um where there's a porn on g3 you
can sacrifice this piece quite often ok
but here he did not play c5 they quite
often play c5 early to make sure that
this roller is not happening I mean
instead of g5 let's say okay I'm taking
and going to castle
yeah black is committed to a king side
attack here definitely let's see night
there yeah there's no reason not to yeah
his bishop on g7 is pretty much dead
meat and also the Queen side is in
trouble but he sometimes will drum up a
dangerous attack normally as mentioned
they play c5 earlier to not even allow
the queenside initiative this actually
seems quite nice for me I I don't don't
really see what his ideas I just want to
play 9 p-5 and win the Queen side okay
um night b5 he's playing rook f6 okay do
I go a4 not sure and I can't do that
it's not bad for night and not be higher
okay so he's just
taking them
and what a funny position b5 is is not
really a checked but still how am i
playing this queen bee three he has 92
check and possibly 94 which seemed stuff
still seems kind of murky
I wonder hmm I'm i really wonder i
played this move here that same just
connecting looks I want what I want to
do is I want to put a roof on this on c6
that would be great if it takes be 5 I
take d6 that that cannot really be that
great I have night a fire for example
later so nothing that I really think
it's that great and maybe I can play
just like night a three Roxy one Luke c6
once my rook hits that would be
excellent really well maybe could be
applying night a three looks looks wacky
but if I get rook to a rope to c6 why
not actually if I go rook c1 he might
take so I'm going to play this
weird-lookin this I still don't see what
he does against this I couldn't play
rook see one queen bee 596 I think
because of possible 92 maybe not maybe
that wasn't threatened ok what is this
is there the sacrifice on g2 I don't
believe that there might be Queen to g6
mm yeah that's definitely the case Queen
g6 I cannot g6 let's do a very tricky
how do we protect that not easy at all
okay you want to infringe e6 screen
before I still 93 m what what what how
long I cannot go queen before in front
viscous of 93 yeah that makes the move
rookie one completely idiotic
time morning I know I cannot go f3 and I
have absolutely no square down and great
great and this position was so good for
white now very badly plate I mean now
those decentralizing moves there they
look strange and very often they are bad
very often they are religious bad
okay maybe I can still fight them but
yeah this Bishop never should have seen
the light of day again
I can still fight them 94 from 9006
player came blundering that that's not a
good idea I was thinking of the other
other okumu actually okay
22 seconds hmm yeah I'm back in this
spending quite some time that's that's
pretty good news check plundering all my
points there are what a crappy game
check check check check hmm losing on
time there may be the position is for
white for its position might be a draw a
trap now I deserve the lost there anyway
this position is strategically I think
almost a win for losing its really
really bad i mean this this white should
just win and i don't care what the comps
s the bishop on g7 is just so so so bad
27 let's let's work this out I went I
went here with this night III plan it
was already the plan down maybe if yeah
maybe this is just not precise at all
this is what what the engine gives
ignoring this yeah maybe I can really
just do that and the check is no problem
the queen is hanging after all now this
is actually pretty big difference there
it's a pretty big difference what is he
doing now yeah i was seeing ghosts I was
just seeing ghosts this is good now I
just have to avoid this this tech down
now we cannot play Queenie aid of course
as I have this pressure on d6 the
computer is suggesting in this move and
now it wants to go quindi one but why
isn't this great i don't get it our
queen age 70 k queen age 7 that is the
idea of this move I see us yes yes a
okay therefore Queen d1 back okay oxy
seven maybe h5 but ok that is good for
white but it is the Dead Set
sophisticated stuff it's not something
that is easily seen
Giada com [ __ ] gives white have a pawn I
really think it's more but some did this
tricky position really this this was
getting I mean my biggest problem was
that is this is a terrible move it's
simply after that I have no reply it
just just completely mindless this is
actually quite good why didn't I do that
that's not bad at all intending to pile
up them it's not bad the reason why I
think this this isn't any good is black
is playing a piece down there I am with
this Bishop on g7 but yeah it's a
practical game it's still very tricky
and as it went I was toast yea somali
let me back into this like here 97 I'm
just better midnight c8 yeah I didn't
didn't see night c8 down just push the
pawn and white wins Jaron yeah it was
just I just played this like a [ __ ] but
Jam their opening result was very nice
actually what they normally play here is
they don't do this but they start with C
5 that's much better keeping c-45 out of
the out of the mix and only then g5 this
is much better in comparison because
then he's the next not busted on the
queenside as it happened in the game
basically okay well thanks for watching